all right so i want you to try and
see how you are within yourself it's a
strike for the temple
it comes up it's a strike to the other
temple
and it comes up the best
if you do it like that you might welcome
join a band leader group
you know you go oh
how good i feel you shouldn't you know
yeah of course if you want to feel like
that
you're moving mass you're concentrating
but the hardest thing to do this is what
i want you to do
elbow not too high oh this is getting
heavy this is getting heavy
that's the bet i want you to check it
shouldn't be
heavy
all right since you used to say
right you hold that there like that you
don't have your elbow eye
he said and um and you just keep it
there and when you're ready in your own
time
you just come up here you do that
and you you settle and even at down
right
we had our elbows till i'm about what
was he
calling it how's he holding up there for
that long i want you to experience the
difficulty of holding it there
i don't want to do it wrong i'm just
saying all right so
each side of the temple you clearly go
right hold it there for a few seconds
other side of the tent will you buy it
when you haven't got a partner you
imagine
your higher temples